as a human being as an interviewer
as a
a researcher and a fan of the ideas in
the field of artificial intelligence i
took a lot away from that conversation
was really inspiring
one of the things is um
the real gift that elon gave me
of
i would say trust and friendship
in
just
sitting there
and thinking so the silence to me was
really powerful that he would trust me
that i wouldn't interrupt him that i
would just sit there and really listen
and then he could sit there we could sit
there in silence and think i think
silence is one of the most intimate
things that two people can share with
each other because
it's having a trust that like you're on
the same page
like with friends
with that in relationships just silence
can be beautiful and uh in a podcast
conversation especially
when there's nerves where there's so
much uncertainty the mics are recording
uh silence is a real gift and it's a i
don't know like i said trust and
friendship
and also it made me realize as a fan of
podcasts how much i love the silence i
used to think
actually the first time we talked i
asked them
what one question would you ask for on
agi system an artificial general
intelligence system
and so he took a long time to answer
that that's so we got more comfortable
through the span of that conversation
and i actually one of the only things i
edited in that conversation was the
length of the pause i actually made it
shorter
than it was
and uh later i realized that
that's not you don't you don't need to
people couldn't wait
it's okay if the pause is 15 seconds
it's good to see a man
a human being think
and
that's one of the beautiful things about
long form
is you have as
much time as you need
to think
you